welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man and it's a big
day to be a Marvel fan with two huge
announcements dropping the first of
which is that we are indeed getting as
spider-man into the spider-verse sequel
and it has a release date the official
Twitter account of into the spider-verse
has teased a big announcement this week
and it didn't disappoint dropping a full
release date for the film the movie will
be coming out on April 8 2022 and whilst
no other details have been released yet
this is some big big news the original
film of course was a brilliant movie
that even went so far is to win an Oscar
and naturally anticipation is really
high for the follow-up whilst I've seen
a couple of people say that the film is
too far away I actually think this is
relatively soon for an animated movie of
this scale Pixar films and the like
often take at least double the time
production wise so this actually doesn't
seem that bad now we have had rumors at
the film will center around Myles and
Gwen building a relationship whilst also
going on adventures through the
multiverse and there are some reports
that Tom Holland may be providing voice
work for the film though as of yet this
is unsubstantiated in a recent interview
Holland did say that he was originally
meant to provide voice work for the
original movie but this was later shut
down and thus there is a possibility
that he could appear in this now that
the contract between Sony and Disney has
been worked out the next bit of news
focuses around Ant Man 3 which will
reportedly be hitting theaters in 2022
as well the movie is going to be held by
director Peyton Reed who was behind the
first ant-man film and its sequel and
man in the wasp the film was notably
absent at the phase 4 announcement panel
and there were rumors that the character
would be moving to Disney Plus however
it's great to see that we are getting a
fully fledged sequel for the character
Paul Road is expected to return but as
of yet there is no mention of hope Hank
or anything of the other characters
though they will likely be back in the
roster it is currently titled
ant-man 3 which is weird because there's
no mention of the wasp but I'm sure we
will get more confirmation on this in
the upcoming days when Marvel's start to
put out information on the prod
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on this news and which one of
the two year most excited for comment
below and let me know and if you enjoy
this video then please give it a thumbs
up and if you want to watch more Marvel
stuff then make sure you check out my
breakdown of the new spider-man far from
home post credits scene which would be
linked at the end we go over the little
details that it teases about how the
world views Mysterio and what it hints
at for spider-man 3 if you want to come
chat to me after the video then make
sure you follow me on twitter at
definition whitey or head over to my
discord server which would be linked in
a description below those are the best
ways to keep up to date with all the
latest videos on the channel so
hopefully i see you over there very soon
this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this I've been definition you've
been the best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]